[Music]
how those in favor does god I'm putting
together team it's me the big guy I took
it off this planet
[Music]
biggest muscle in the body I've got lots
of muscles so technically more brains
for ragnarok with a pg-13 everywhere
November 3rd
you must be hella and for son of Odin
really you don't look like him perhaps
we can come to an arrangement you sound
like him kneel beg your pardon
kneel
before your queen
I don't think so it's not possible
darling you have no idea what it's
possible
[Music]
[Applause]
hey hey we know each other
he's a friend from work
[Applause]
everybody thought you were dead so much
has happened since I last saw you lost
my hammer like yesterday so that's still
pretty fresh Loki Loki Loki's alive you
believe it he's like he's up there okay
[Applause]
okay I thought the world are you I
thought where I'm gonna find
side-by-side forever but at the end of
the day or you and I me and oh maybe
they're still good at new but let's be
honest our paths diverged a long time
yeah
let's pray for the best that we never
see each other again that's what you
always wanted
needless to get help what get help
no come on I hate it it's great it works
every time
humiliating do you have a plan no we're
doing it we are not doing get help so
much has happened since I last saw you
I lost my hammer like yesterday sir
that's we're still pretty fresh and then
I went on a journey of self-discovery
but I love you
[Music]
where are we you have no idea I Love You
God is the death is invaded us God oh I
missed this
and you and I had a fight or something
did I win
[Music]
no I want easily this in sound right
well that's true
as god is dead little be reborn in my
image I thought you'd be glad to see me
here to stop her here now to prevent
Ragnarok the end of everything
so I'm putting together team
like the old days
surprise this will be such fun
he's a fighter
we go
I'm not a queen or a monster
the goddess of death
what were you the god of again
[Music]
we're the same you and I just a couple
of hotheaded fools
yes saying oh like fire door like water
kind of both like fire the whole like
raging fire so I like smoldering for the
goddess of death is invaded as God
destiny has dire plans for you my friend
I have dire plans for destiny I'm going
to stop up hello it's me Loki the big
guy and you
for ragnarok with AP g---thirteen
everywhere November 3rd welcome voice
activation required on November 3rd
access tonight Thunder tonight Prince of
Asgard strongest welcome strongest
Avenger Oh what for Ragnarok for the
pg-13 in theatres November 3rd get
tickets now yeah
in this film we wanted to kind of strip
it back and wanted have more fun with it
you know I'm taka had the exact same
idea and we were both saying it's Thor
Ragnarok it's trying to have more
attitude
Ragnarok sort of a new cycle from the
life of the world all the realms of the
universe it's the destruction of the
old' and the rebirth of the new that's
really exciting to me surprise this
would be such fun the way that I've
approached this is to rebuild it in a
new way look great dude
finally I think it's just a perfect mix
for where the character and story need
to go you know different costumes
different weapons different cast or
characters to work or give you a
different energy Thor has been a crisis
he never went back to Asgard to claim
the throne he wanted adventure when we
pick him up he's at the end of this
search for himself
we're the ones we serve on this trip I'd
say the odds are about a million fun
you know I want this to take people on a
ride and enjoy some comedy into it an
adventure that keeps people laughing
along the way it also has a spectacle
and the stuff that it gets people
excited he's a fighter
[Music]
oh I know what you're thinking
how did this happen
well it's a long story
Pascal is dead
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
what have you brought today tell me
[Music]
it's main event time
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we know each other he's a friend from
work
[Music]
the hell is the goddess of death and
I've had incredible fun playing her oh I
miss this tell us the first female
villain that we've had in the Marvel
film and kate has destroyed the idea of
your typical villain kneel before your
queen loved working with cate blanchett
I was so excited to see what she was
gonna do it hello as this insane
off-kilter attitude you know like a snap
boy
how would you like a job
I think the best villains are always
those that to you kind of love and hate
what they do but you sort of understand
it there's a logic to it she wants to
come back home and be accepted and she
wants what is your in my seat
I would love for someone else to rule
but it can't be you you're just the
worst some of the happiest times have
been fading people out I've really
enjoyed us like I don't speak today I
can just throw axes into someone's gosh
that's been good
hello the goddess of death is invaded
our God started putting together a team
to stop everybody's worked so hard on
this movie for so many years
and to come here tonight and finally
show it to the world and get that
reaction it's my favorite part of the
whole experience without that these fans
would never jump inside to come to a
premiere and have that kind of response
is amazing and how lucky I am I think
what is bright is how completely the
fans own the universe and how I mean
this is for them you know I think we all
really wanted to break all the rules at
this movie but still you know follow the
tradition Taika Waititi he's a brilliant
director and and then this cast I must
be dreaming that the cast have been
together and I get to come here and
celebrate with them so the celebration
eventually getting the job done the
enthusiasm for the for the Marvel
Universe is growing and more people have
joined there are more characters and
it's sort of more epic and the fans have
been there it's so great to be met with
the excitement that fans have I've been
outside inciting everybody thought about
so this is awesome you know just to rock
up here tonight and see all these
wonderful people out here supporting us
as it's mumbling Cate Blanchett Jeff
Goldblum Mark Ruffalo
riddles and Tessa Thompson Carlo and
everyone sort of realized the
opportunity we had to sort of recreate
this and have the same confidence in
doing it that we did when we get to a
part three we think okay now it's time
to do something different to do
something unexpected and that's why we
hired Taika Waititi he always brings us
uniqueness as he makes comedy and just a
sense of fun so everything he does it's
very exciting could be there in Thor in
the world of thought yeah just sort of
big part of Tigers take on the whole
thing it's kind of a Thor reboot
extraordinaire
I wanted to obviously respect what the
first two films are done but also use
that as a bit of a launching pad to try
new something fairy friends do and I had
a fight recently right that's true Chris
Hemsworth is hilarious in it it just is
every day was about doing something
different Kentucky risks and fracking
the old version and reinvent to give and
I think we did that and it was the best
experience I've had
[Applause]
what were you the god of again
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen this is what you
become for
main event time
Oh miss this I'm putting together a team
No
yeah school de revenge's revenge us you
know I mean we don't have to have a name
we have no name
[Music]
get tickets now
[Music]